Chers amis, bienvenue dans cette deuxième vidéo sur ...
*chute du fond vert*
Je regrette ce que je viens de faire
Bienvenue dans cette deuxième vidéo sur VRCHAT
La première vous avait énormément plu
On va aujourd'hui rejouer pendant quelques heures et refaire des rencontres formidables
Préparez-vous à des situations "rocambolesques"
Et à avoir mal au yeux pendant 4 heures après ce tournage
*Bruit bizarre*
HELLO ? WHO IS... ... HELLO ? EXCUSE ME ?
What were you doing with that ?
I..I don't know... I am just looking at some videos on the internet...
You are Amixem ?
No... No! No-no !
You are... You are Amixem ? You're the french youtuber ?
I'm squeezie, bro !
Oh YES ! I KNOW YOU YOU'RE VERY FAMOUS !
Pourquoi on parle Anglais alors qu'il n'y a que nous?
Je ne sais pas (on peut ptêtre parler français...)
*rires*
Les amis, vous l'aurez compris
Nous sommes aujourd'hui avec Amixem même si il ne ressemble pas du tout à Amixem dans ce jeu
C'est moi!
Vous avez été très nombreux à nous demander suite à nos deux vidéos de faire
un truc sur VRCHAT ensemble
C'est aujourd'hui le moment
C'est parti!
Oui!
"Je suis parler le français" OOHH!
On est d'accord qu'il a un truc de Russe au dessus de la tronche?
Bah ouais, il parle français mais il est totalement Russe
Hé, il écris chinois maintenant!
Non, il écrit Japonais!
Attends regarde, je peux effacer ce qu'il fait, c'est horrible, regarde!
*rires*
Oh là! Oh là! Qui a dit ça?
Vas-y on change de monde du coup ou pas?
Oui, totalement!
Ah ouais, d'accord
What the f*ck? *rires*
Ne me parles pas comme ça, Evoli
ça va pas le faire!
Pourquoi on te choisirais alors qu'à côté il y a Carapuce, espèce de petite merde?
C'est vrai ça
Parce que je m'appelle "Heat The Meat" mon pote!
Ta voix elle ne va pas du tout avec toi, arrêtes ça !
Mais oui! Fait une voix mignonne!
Mais oui, sois mignon, merde!
Arrête de faire une voix grave, bordel!
On recommence! C'est pas grave, on recommence!
Oh, Evoli! Viens me faire un câlin!
Oh, il y a Evoli!
Ouiiii!
AAAAH! *rires*
Là c'est mieux!
*musique : Shake It ! - Vocaloïd*
*rires*
On est vraiment en train de danser dans un monde virtuel, vieux!
On l'a jamais fait dans la vraie vie, on le fait pour la première fois dans VRCHAT!
ça n'a plus aucun sens, aucun intérêt, mais dans la vraie vie c'est de la merde!
*rires*
Ouaah! Il y a Jack Sparrow!
J'ai acheté tout tes albums, j'adore ce que tu fais!
Ok, y'a Slender Max ! Fait gaffe, y'a Slender, y'a Slender! Fait gaffe!
OH NON, MAXIME IL T'ATTAQUE! MAXIME IL T'ATTAQUE!
MAXIME IL T'ATTAQUE, FUIS, COURS! IL COURS!
MAXIME FUIS! J'viens t'aider, j'viens t'aider! J'lui met une patate!
PATATE! FILS DE P*TE!
En fait, tu vois l'écran qui est là?
Wow !
En fait il filme avec une caméra qui est là bas
Et il faut la récupérer pour faire de la merde sur l'écran
OH ! J'AI LA CAMERA ! JE SUIS SUR GRAND ECRAN
OUH !
Je te vois en grand Max, t'es trop beau !
Et bienvenue dans mon nouveau Vlog !
Je vais faire un truc incroyable dans ce Vlog
Je vais sauter depuis le toit devant tout le monde
C'est un exploit assez fou que je vais réaliser, Mesdames et Messieurs aujourd'hui ! C'est maintenant !
Ah !!
C'était pas si impressionnant...
C'était pas ouf, clairement
Mec ! Je suis en train de me battre avec un mec, il veut me prendre mon coeur
J'ai un coeur et il veut me le prendre
Je viens t'aider, je viens t'aider, je viens t'aider bro
Il est où ? Il est où le batard ?
Stop ! Stop faut que je te le file mec
Oh il te la pris, il te l'a pris !
Oui il l'a pris, il est où ?
Oh il m'a raté, je l'ai raté ! Il est là, il est là, il est là !
Viens on va le choper, on va le choper !
Il est allé dans un igloo, il est allé dans un igloo !
J'ai le coeur, j'ai le coeur !
Non il me l'a repris !
Je suis vers l'escalier derrière
Il me l'a repris, il est tombé en bas !
Je lui cours après, je lui cours après Max, je lui cours après
Je lui ai pris bro, je lui ai pris, je lui ai pris, je lui ai pris !
Vas-y cours, cours !
Je lui ai pris, je cours Amixem !
Je le met en l'air le coeur !
IL L'A REPRIS !!
Il l'a repris ? Attends ch'uis là, ch'uis là, j'l'ai !
Prends le ! Prends le !
HAHA IL SE FAIT FRIENDZONE DEVANT MOI !
Il a dit okay ! IL A DIT OKAY !
*rires* A-HAHA IL EST TROP MIGNON !
*Rires*
Wouahou... Viens là...
On va voir d'autres personnes pour voir si ils dorment bien
Ouais
Il est coincé dans le jeu, ça fait deux ans
Il y a un avion qui dort mec, il y a un avion qui dort
Salut, petit avion. Tu dors ?
Il y a un monde c'est un arrêt de bus
Zéro fun le mec. Pire joueur. On est face au pire joueur de tout VRCHAT
Vraiment, il est là, on l'a trouvé
Moi je vais le laisser au montage vraiment pour les gens voient que c'est aussi ça
Ne jouez pas à VRCHAT, c'est 99% du temps des gens comme ça